la genetica cosa può fare selezionare le
caratteristiche fisiche e mentali
perfetta in ogni bambino che deve
nascere
genere in italia
in un futuro non troppo lontano
il nostro dna determinerà tutto di noi
una minuscola goccia di sangue
risaliva un capello
decideranno che lavoro potrai fare e
potrai sposare
quali risultati potrai raggiungere
in una società in cui il successo viene
determinato dalla genetica
e i cui membri vengono divisi per virali
di perfezione
ben tenuti a gattaca
benvenuti a gattaca e benvenuti nel mio
genoma oggi faremo un salto nel futuro
passando attraverso questo film di
fantascienza del 1997 quindi poco più di
20 anni un film che oggi è molto vicino
a raccontarci la situazione reale e qui
il pensiero parallelo ricordate che
quello se non l'avete mai visto non lo
ricordate scaricatelo lo trovate
sicuramente su youtube e vedrete la
storia di una società in cui il destino
delle persone come avete sentito dipende
dal proprio patrimonio genetico è la
storia di un uomo che vuol fare
l'astronauta
ma ha problemi genetici di
predisposizione all'infarto per cui per
questo viene scartato naturalmente un
film per cui il messaggio che emerge è
che la volontà dell'uomo è superiore al
suo fisico per cui quest'uomo che
dovrebbe morire di infarto in realtà
riesce a fare l'astronauta a raggiungere
i suoi obiettivi
perché è diventato reale questo film
perché le tecnologie che sono presentate
per caratterizzare patrimonio genetico
degli essere umani oggi li abbiamo a
disposizione negli ultimi 15 anni c'è
stato un progresso formidabile nelle
tecnologie che solo nel 2001 hanno
portato a decodificare il genoma
dell'homo sapiens
non era genoma di una singola persona
era il genoma di una serie di persone
che doveva rappresentare il patrimonio
genetico dell'umanità e sono diversi
anni dopo se guardate il costo per
sequenziare quel genoma 3 miliardi di
dollari per sequenziare 3 miliardi di
basi
era un corso è un tempo uno sforzo tale
da rendere impossibile caratterizzare il
patrimonio genetico di ciascuno di noi
ma vedete che nel 2014 questo costo
assolutamente contenuto parliamo abbiamo
abbattuto la barriera dei mille dollari
per cui questo questa operazione
caratterizzare interpretare il genoma di
ciascuno di noi costa ormai poco più di
una qualsiasi analisi complessa che
possiamo fare in ospedale con una grande
differenza che così come i diamanti pure
il genoma e per sempre quando l'avete
letto una volta non cambierà nel corso
della vita per cui avrete sempre a
disposizione le informazioni che esso
contiene e
se avete guardato scusate sono dato
troppo in fretta sto cercando di fare
un'altra cosa estremamente laterale far
dialogare apple con microsoft che sta
sotto lì e quindi
allora
vedete che questo trend è abbastanza già
conosciuto da noi se guardate quello che
è successo nel campo dell'informatica
vedete
che siamo passati da computer che
costavano 6 milioni di dollari pesavano
27 tonnellate e consumavano 150 kilowatt
di energia elettrica per poter fare
pochissime operazioni siamo arrivati ad
avere personal computer e personal
computer nonostante posti molto di più
di un personal genome
ha cambiato la nostra vita
io ricordo ero un tesista all'epoca e
sono stato il primo tesista che ha
scritto la propria tesi con un pc che
era appena arrivato
ricordo che i miei colleghi di qualche
mese più anziani di me invece ancora
avevano scritto la loro tesi con la
macchina da scrivere e ho apprezzato
questo impatto formidabile che questa
tecnologia ha avuto sulla nostra vita
molti di voi sono così giovani che sono
nati dopo che io scrivevo quella tesi e
col pc ma abbia provate a pensare in
modo laterale appunto all'impatto che a
poter salvare un documento un'idea
poterla trasferire su un computer
salvarla richiamarla modificarla
stamparla una cosa fantastica
bene questo tipo di impatto adesso nella
nostra società lo può avere anche
l'analisi del nostro dio no ma si parla
di genoma questa diapositiva vi racconta
qualcosina per chi fosse poco familiare
con queste cose voi sapete che abbiamo
46 cromosomi nelle nostre cellule 23 che
vengono da nostra madre 23 che vengono
da nostro padre e cromosomi xy sono
quelli che ci danno che determinano il
nostro sesso ma soprattutto i cromosomi
contengono ciò che noi siamo le cellule
non fanno altro che prendere il libretto
di istruzioni che il dna che sta lì
dentro leggerlo tutto e costruire
l'organismo quindi quello che noi siamo
è esattamente quello che sta scritto nel
nostro manuale delle istruzioni per cui
conoscere questo manuale delle
istruzioni
altro pensiero estremamente laterale ci
dice quello che noi siamo è vero
esiste l'anima come gattaca sottolinea
non c'è un gene per l'anima quindi c'è
un qualcosa di superiore a quello che
sta scritto nel nostro libretto delle
istruzioni però dobbiamo ricordare che
molto di ciò che siamo e molto di quello
che facciamo in fondo sa scritto lì e
questo e un libretto che a volte può
avere degli errori per cui conoscere
questi errori permette a noi di riuscire
a capire quali sono per esempio le basi
genetiche di numerose malattie
terribili come i tumori all infarto
o che sono responsabili di alcune
malattie rare e che determinano queste
variazioni anche le diverse risposte ai
farmaci io altro pensiero laterale mi
aspetto che nel giro di pochissimo tempo
noi andremo in farmacia e assumeremo un
farmaco che è compatibile con nostro
patrimonio genetico ci sarà questa vera
medicina personalizzata o
farmacogenomica per cui ad ogni
patrimonio genetico cosi come in gattaca
veniva assegnato un lavoro qua verrà
assegnato un farmaco che permette
all'individuo di rispondere in maniera
perfetta potremmo anche capire quali
sono i geni che permettono di vivere a
lungo oggi cominciamo a pensare che
la lunga vita sia dovuta all'assenza di
errori gravi nel nostro manuale delle
istruzioni
noi viviamo a lungo perché non abbiamo
predisposizioni genetiche che ci portano
ad
avere malattie gravi che purtroppo
accorciano la nostra vita ma potremmo
anche cercare di capire per esempio
perché questo signore è ancora vivo
nonostante la quantità di
droghe e alcol che ha assunto come
potete vedere in basso a sinistra questo
è il primo genoma sequenziato per
ragioni non mediche quindi veramente
curiosità possiamo anche capire
e cercare
in stile gattaca
quali sono le caratteristiche genetiche
che ci permettono di essere predisposti
per
determinati sport io penso che anche se
adesso hanno scoperto qual è la variante
che permette di fare sport pesanti basta
guardare il mio fisico per capire che
non serve un test genetico
io non sarò mai un sollevatore di pesi
così come non penso che serve un'analisi
genetica per capire se io sono oppure
non sono soddisfatto del mio stato
matrimoniale perché ognuno dei
polimorfismi su questo gene che vedete
in basso non ho neanche voluto guardare
queste cose sono curiosità però che
mi permettono di introdurre il mio
genoma e di spiegarvi le ragioni per cui
in fondo io mi sono sequenziato e mi
sono decodificati io sono un genetista
non sono un medico quindi a verona da
diversi anni sequenzia mo praticamente
tutti gli organismi viventi ultimamente
ci è capitato di sequenziare anche
decodificare l'uomo da genetista il
primo genoma umano che ha voluto
sequenziare a verona è stato
naturalmente il mio per curiosità sono
un genetista questa è la prima ragione
la seconda ragione è che volevo capire
che cosa si prova a leggere il proprio
dna è molto difficile quando
non essendo medici si comincia a
lavorare su pazienti che sono affetti da
malattie e questi pazienti
spiegano il timore di la paura di
leggere quello che sta scritto nel
proprio patrimonio genetico dicono è
facile che tu legga il mio genoma mai
provato a leggere il tuo ecco io ho
provato a rispondere questa domanda ho
provato a leggere il mio genoma e ho
cercato di capire la difficoltà con la
quale pure io genetista approcciamo
informazioni che potevano essere
estremamente difficili da accettare come
una predisposizione alcune malattie
genetiche hanno
valori e di insorgenza estremamente
elevati per cui trovare alcune varianti
significa avere prima o poi sicuramente
lo sviluppo di quella malattia e la
terza ragione anche per la privacy per
fortuna non possiamo mostrare i dati
degli altri per cui per esempio una in
un'occasione come questa non avrei
potuto mostrare alcun genoma se non il
mio appunto per queste ragioni essendo
il mio posso farci quello che voglio e
allora
è detto al mio genoma su questo ipad
tutto qua dentro adesso è protetto per
la privacy mia con una password che non
riuscite a leggere
e signore e signori benvenuti nel mio
genoma immaginate di essere su google
map immaginate di essere con livello di
zoom minore per cui vedete il globo
terrestre
ok ma vedete i miei cromosomi vedete
tutti i miei autosomi che sono i
cromosomi non sessuali più lixil y ora
proviamo a fare come su google proviamo
a zoomare all'interno e quindi prendiamo
per esempio il mio cromosoma numero uno
ci entriamo adesso il sistema ancora un
pochetto lento ma vi fa vedere che ci
sono lo vedete a destra
2.500 istruzioni su questo cromosoma
istruzioni che hanno a che fare con
diverse condizioni che potete vedere
nella sinistra purtroppo la prima che
appare l'alcolismo
io sono piacentino e rassegna sono
arrivato a verona
penso che sia una vera interazione
genotipo ambiente in questo caso mi sono
innamorato del vino
adesso vi faccio vedere cosa posso fare
per esempio posso vedere questa è una
cosa incredibile una mutazione per cui
si assuma un antidepressivo vado in
depressione più di quanto può fare una
persona normale e questo vi spiega
l'importanza di poter un giorno
associare il farmaco al patrimonio
genetico ma come vi dicevo così come
google io posso entrare nel mio
cromosoma e cominciare ad allargare
quindi zum zum zum sono a livello di
stato poi posso arrivare a livello di
città per poi arrivare alla fine
vedete sono partito da 250 milioni di
base adesso sono a 135.000 lo vedete in
basso a sinistra al largo al largo poi
adesso vedo le varianti in questo bar i
viola che vedete sono le varianti
rispetto al genoma di riferimento quindi
sono le cose che caratterizzano me
rispetto
a voi ea un certo punto sistema va in
stallo perché deve cambiare database
ecco allarga ancora larga ancora allarga
ancora ecco adesso sto leggendo così
come se fossi su google map e vedessi le
strade con il nome della strada io qua
sto leggendo il mio dna e sotto vedete
reference è il reference del genoma di
riferimento è quello sopra il mio
correnti nome è il mio genoma per cui io
vedo che sono praticamente uguali al
genoma di riferimento qua c'è una
variante che una variante associata
appunto a questa diversa risposta all
anti depressivo che mi porta appunto ad
andare in depressione ma adesso vi
faccio vedere la cosa più difficile che
è stata per me a guardare andare a
vedere le malattie
che sono di cui o predisposizioni
genetiche
ne ho diverse ma devo dire sono almeno
per quello che conosciamo oggi siamo
agli inizi ancora di una nuova era che
quella di comprendere quello che sta
scritto nel nostro genoma per cui le
informazioni che abbiamo sono ancora
estremamente limitate però cominciamo ad
averle o predisposizione ad alcune
malattie ma niente di gravissimo se non
fosse che morirò un giorno
improvvisamente ma spero di notte perché
in un letto perché ho una
predisposizione genetica per la sindrome
del qt lungo che è
un difetto nella ripolarizzazione del
cuore dopo il battito che determina la
morte improvvisa è una delle cause per
cui improvvisamente ogni tanto l'ho
sentito i calciatori o atleti che stanno
svolgendo la loro attività si accasciano
al suolo e muoiono ora non entro nei
dettagli ma se guardate su google news
troverete nella seconda notizia
adesso è diventata la quarta per quarta
cambia e siamo online store sistema
estremamente dinamico per cui è già
cambiato la quarta notizia è
un ragazzo di 21 anni il padre entra in
camera sua al mattino e lo trova morto
non si erano accorti che aveva questa
predisposizione genetica che è stata
osservata in questo caso solo
allora
questa
mia malattia
ancora in un la sviluppo
anche essere su questo palco porta al
all'accelerazione del battito una
persona che soffre di questa sindrome
dovrebbe impedire qualsiasi dovrebbe
bloccare qualsiasi emozione quindi
dovrei prendere beta bloccanti dovrei
stare a casa sempre evitare che i
colleghi
e gli amici la moglie la famiglia mi
faccia arrabbiare invece una vita
estremamente stressante
sono ancora vivo non entro nei dettagli
di questa cosa ma voglio farmi vedere
una cosa
la settimana scorsa
sapendo di venire qui ho deciso ho
convinto un collega medico
qui di borgo roma a sottopormi all'esame
a farmi l'elettrocardiogramma e dirmi se
poteva dimostrare clinicamente quello
che la genetica mi diceva cioè che io
soffro della sindrome del qt lungo la
sindrome del qt lungo vedete è lo spazio
che passa tra cui ti quando questo
spazio temporale superiore a un certo
valore
vuol dire che il cuore a problemi e
praticamente sono problemi elettrici e
viene a mancare segnale improvvisamente
il segnale non è sufficiente il cuore si
ferma e la persona in assenza di un
defibrillatore è destinata a morire bene
il valore che io ho e 504 questo medico
sorpreso e preoccupato mi ha detto i
maschi hanno valore generalmente sotto i
440 le femmine sotto i 460 non
consideriamo il valore del qt
pericoloso quando è sotto i 480 sopra i
480 a bisogna che
proseguiamo con le analisi e forse
dovrai arrivare
a fare quello che ha fatto
l'astronauta in gattaca cioè a
ingannare i medici
nascondendo loro le informazioni
genetiche e vivendo la mia vita convinto
che il mio spirito sia comunque
superiore
a quello che sta scritto nel mio
patrimonio genetico
dal genetista però non posso ricordare
che questa è la genetica è così che
funziona
speriamo gattaca abbia avuto ragione
grazie